but you have to do it
[Music]
here
although it could be facebook
everything is fine
[Music]
let them
know what they are talking about
how delicious
[Music]
you can
although in the media
you want to see
[Music] it
's true
[Music]
ah
[  Music] I
don't
ex cons
any wedge
and
well I go every day
[Music]
I'm going to rest
[Music] it
's a clear
online record
[Music]
doing
it no one knows or is true
but that's
in the unsj
ect
gray hair
here
strauss kahn
and so on to fulfill them
[Music]
but there
are no more functions
[Music]
webber
more
[Music]
but nothing
get
[Music]
from blog
in the  trailer
amen
ah
[Music]
and
ah
[Music]
crisis
guasave
[Music]
is channel
persona
[Music
] sometimes you can have
[Music]
e
ansa
[Music]
[Music]  ]
[Music] the
same
[Music]
is ideal
of claws
what
you
the scene
ah
or not
the night
p  ues every day
well no good
and
one is that when it snows
yes
polarization
well
it's okay no it's
not
exact
yes
and back new life
[Music]
well
and nothing else
or put
ah
by the way
unfortunate destroyed
[Music]
by time
them
[Music]  ]
[Music]
working so
stay
[Music]
is this
although avocados sake
[Music]
ghana
until when
the inner layer  and here comes my court
is to know
amaya
[Music]
and yes
have a chance
[Music]
but we have
thought it was